[Music]
you're leading the pack you are in the
top position Carrie Ann Inaba
[Applause]
we know Tonioli back down
I know I'm gonna wake up tomorrow
they'll be like yeah I was three three
three was your score you know I'm in
like a fantasy land like it's like this
is my like my dream situation I go on
stage I'm so nervous like I'm literally
a disaster out here like I'm a disaster
do you think I should be getting better
but like I'm a disaster but it just it
comes out like I don't know when or are
you channeling like cuz I was like great
who is that no idea literally he's a
completely different person in
rehearsals and then also that music
comes on and we're live and he's like I
love it though I love this so much I
know I keep saying that but I really
really do and every episode like before
the show starts before I dance I'm like
why am I doing this this is the most
torturous thing I've ever done and then
immediately after I'm like this is the
greatest thing on the planet like why
didn't I do this 12 years ago
well I mean anybody that wears a jacket
like this and having a good night I mean
you got to be you got to get it off I'm
going out on the town tonight
[Music]
I bought the spray tans did you go
through the spray tan it's sort of like
a rite of passage I didn't you know I
was landing there like Oh skin skin skin
I'm like I'm still wearing four layers
because there's nothing to go I unbutton
one button that's pretty good for me
I've got seven hairs I've been growing
for 31 years
[Music]